one of the best insiders writers have
covering the NBA is mark Stein for the
New York Times kind enough to join us
good morning mark how are you
I'm good sir apologize in advance for
any bonus Airport Airport noise you guys
get I'm at DFW getting ready to get on a
plane so bear with me okay the immediate
effect of Kevin Durant's injury on free
agency is what the immediate effect is
actually that we can't tell you the
immediate effect it's so sudden and so
jarring that you know Durant's got agree
you first and I know we all want these
answers and free agencies it's June 30th
now it's been moved up six hours it's
basically two weeks away but no one's
still I don't think there's still anyone
beyond Durant and rich Klieman is his
business manager who could tell you what
he's going to do and they're not telling
us about I think a lot of people believe
that the chances of him staying have
increased whether that's hmm by opting
in or opting out and getting a long term
deal with the Warriors but regrettably
it is still more guesswork than people
in my line of work we want to admit you
also have the timing of the NBA Finals
and then the draft is next week I don't
know if the pelicans want to get a deal
for Anthony Davis done prior to the
draft is that your understanding yeah
they do they definitely do I mean
there's they're pushing hard for it
they're you know the Lakers and Celtics
are known to be after him
you know if there's other teams that
want to be daring and want to pull up
they want to use the Oklahoma City
blueprint and like the Thunder traded
for Paul George or of more relevance
using the Toronto blueprint and gambling
on Kawhi Leonard those teams have the
opportunity but you know right now it's
the Lakers and the Celtics that are the
focus and the pelicans definitely would
it's close to get a deal done before the
draft now will that happen for the
Lakers to make it happen it's really
going to hinge on that
for PIC they've got to find someone out
there that really likes that number for
pickin is going to give some give New
Orleans something more appealing than
what's currently on the table because
the Lakers by themselves don't they
don't have enough to get Anthony Davis
the problem is most draft experts would
tell you this is depending on the eye of
the beholder it's a two player draft or
a three player draft in terms of
franchise players and of course the
Lakers at the fourth pick so how much
they can actually fetch for number four
that remains to be seen who's in a more
envious position right now the pelicans
or the Lakers in this situation I
actually I like the pelicans position I
think they're going to come out of this
with a really good team David Griffin
he's going to trade him event and he's
going to get a lot for Anthony Davis
they still got true holidays one of the
most underrated players in this league
one of the most coveted players in this
league one of the best two-way cards in
this league they're bringing in Zion
they've already got your holiday they're
going to get a lot for Anthony Davis the
pelicans are going to rebound from this
horrific season they just endured pretty
well the Lakers they need to get Anthony
Davis but if they are they're not in the
free-agent game right now for anybody
certificate and I think their hope is
that they pull off the Davis trade and
now a free agent say wait a minute
LeBron Anthony Davis maybe I need to
give this maybe I need to give Laker
land another look but getting Davis is
the first domino for the Lakers the must
Domino he's Mark Steyn New York Times
NBA writer joining us Dan Patrick show
but I was also looking at this if I'm
the Lakers and and I have a little bit
of leverage because I I know that
Anthony Davis is agent rich Pahl's
already told the Celtics hey he's not
gonna sign long-term deal with you
whether that's true or not but he's
already sending the message look he's
gonna eventually get here we don't have
to give up as much as we need to because
it feels like Kyle Kuzma is gonna be
kept in the cupboard here and they're
not gonna let him out I just don't know
if you get that if I'm New Orleans
there's no way I'd take Lonzo ball the
fourth pick and
Brandon Ingram for Anthony Davis here
kuzmin's got to be involved oh wait I
mean look that realistically they
haven't soul said I mean that's not
their preference they've lived under
this Anthony Davis trade cloud since
January and really before that before
company Davis made the trade request we
you know that's like me were we're
asking them about the about Anthony
Davis the future every day so they've
been living with this for nearly a year
already they really don't want to go all
the way to February but they do have
that option
look you just know there are a lot of
people around leagues who sink but again
these are opinions for diction's
observations this is not reported
knowledge I want to underline that but
just a hypothetical you know what if
what if it whatever team like Denver
just said you know what we want to we
want to get in the game in gam but we
have a good team we got a lot of assets
we want to just take a one-year run at
Anthony Davis so there are teams out
there that have the ability to do it if
they want to get in and take the risk
and you know it is conceivable that
executives around the league you're
gonna look at what what's happened in
Toronto and look at what the Raptors did
to bring in Kawhi Leonard and you know
now everyone in Toronto says they're
going to be ok as Kauai leaves after
this I'm not so sure let's actually see
that play out but in the in the short
term if you're a rapper sand you have to
be giddy that your team rolled the dice
on Kawhi Leonard they didn't know if
they'd have him fourth of the season
don't know they keep them didn't know he
was going to tell see and look how it's
worked out and I also look at Durant and
if I'm the Knicks or any of these teams
that you know bidding for services I
come out and say to him look we'll give
you your max deal
you can rehab on our dime here we're in
it long long haul here you know he's
still gonna get all the teams that
wanted it still want it right now look
at it from his perspective you know this
is the worst injury you can have in
basketball history tells us that there
is no injury that basketball players
dread more than an Achilles tear even if
the rehab goes great and given Durant's
work ethic you expect that it would it
is still a real
heart injury to come back from and on
day one you're not what's work I'm not
gonna sit here and say Durant can't be
what he's been but it's it's probably
going to take him more than just the
rehab to get back on the floor do you
want to go to the Knicks or you're
expected to carry a franchise that has
been miserable for two decades or would
you rather go back to Golden State and
let Steph and clay and draymond green
carry the load at the beginning while
you're working your way back mmm with an
organization and the training staff you
already know I would think if I'm Durant
that that scenario is more appealing is
he he might be ready to play next season
in February is he ready to carry a team
in secretary that's a huge matter of
debate but Marc I was curious about the
medical staff with the Warriors is he
comfortable with them after what just
happened here and do you want them to
oversee you're rehabbing with this
Achilles injury well and that's look
yeah I know you said it in your intro
because I was me with as time will go on
we're gonna learn more about this we
don't we don't know all the ins and outs
and and and what happened behind the
scenes now if you read Kevin Durant
Instagram post he said he was out there
because he wanted to be out there
because that's what he does Hooper she
wanted to play I think that's basically
him taking at least some measure of
responsibility for for being out there
now if we come if she was if Durant was
unhappy with the process that led to him
being clear we're eventually going here
that knew and that will surely be cited
as a reason if he decides not to go back
but to this point we have no evidence
you know we have no evidence that
there's dismay there well I and I wasn't
gonna point the finger of blame at
anybody until Steve Steve Kerr was asked
about this and he said you have Sam
asked Bob Meyers and then Bob Meyers the
GM says well if you're gonna blame
somebody blame me what why why am i
blamed why are you putting yourself out
there to blame if everybody did their
due diligence here then why are we
pointing fingers or need to well I
actually look at it completely different
I thought
that's the Warriors trying to do the
professional responsible thing knowing
that this binge is going to be under the
microscope like nothing like nothing
that's happened in these last five years
for them and the reason Steve Kerr
handed those questions off the bob was
because of the immediate aftermath they
wanted one voice to be speaking for the
whole organization and they decided I
was gonna be Bob Myers and Bob Myers
went up to the podium and took the
questions I don't know how many GM's
would have done that in the aftermath of
such a bad injury so no courage rested
yesterday it's not like Steve was going
to say I'm never going to discuss this
for the rest of my career I just think
in the immediate aftermath on the night
it happened they wanted one guy
basically answer the question in three
weeks where is Kevin Durant oh man I
knew you're gonna say okay I don't know
it I'm but that's my that's my field
yeah I started to get a sense of him
you know maybe staying for one year even
before the injury like one more year at
Golden State and getting one more chance
for a championship and then leaving
after that but with this I'm not quite
sure and certainly trust your insights
better than mine in three weeks where's
Anthony Davis man I actually for some
strange reason even though recent events
should give us no confidence to speak of
it this way I kind of feel like the
Lakers are gonna find a way find a way
to get this straight up that they're
gonna find someone who sees enough value
and number four to give the pelicans the
peace they want beyond you know if you
said Ingram and laws of all that's not
nearly enough for Anthony Davis they're
gonna need something you know something
beyond that but I I do think the Lakers
are gonna find a litt is LeBron
shoppable oh yeah now they're not that
doesn't mean they're going to but I mean
but still like still watch it now what
would he be worth if all of a sudden
Lakers said hey LeBron is available make
your offers what's he worth
I mean you know I haven't specifically
diced it up to give you an exact package
but you know I I would I would think
that they would they would be able to
find a workable trade I mean you know if
you're the Lakers and you've been
through everything that they've been
through over the last two years
especially do you want that on your
resume to the team that traded LeBron
James they got enough issues over there
but you know what Mark I brought this up
and you know Van Gundy said the same
thing I
I would shop if I could get younger if
you said I can trade LeBron for Anthony
Davis would you do that if you're the
Lakers yeah I think they probably like
just you'd have to know what else was
around it I mean just straight up
probably not but but look they've been
out of the playoffs six years yeah
before this drought they didn't have six
month layoff seasons in their whole
history so it's the worst position this
franchise has ever been
they have LeBron James they're not
looking to trade in there they're
thinking is or one Domino away from
being right back in the mid this they
pulled the Davis trade off especially
before free agency that they can now go
into fridges and we've got LeBron and
Davis I mean they're they're not far
away from being right back at the mix
and so you know I it's true it was too
hard to get LeBron I you know what
trading him as trading him as the
ultimate last resort safe travels mark
thanks for joining us we appreciate your
time
that's Mark Steyn New York Times NBA
writer worked with him at the mothership
for quite some time for more Dan Patrick
show tune in the audience channel 239 on
DirecTV stream for free on BR live or
download the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]